how do you pick your projects like I
mean did a fortune teller tell you to do
50 First Dates or Wedding Singer no so
how do you do it both of those I went
after with like a tenacity of a
um rabid
um rabies riddled uh dog oh okay
um I just I I begged Adam Sandler to
meet me because I was so convinced that
we should be cinematic soul mates I
brought him a script called frigid and
impotent
sounds like a hit dark comedy and I was
like would you want to do something like
this or would you want to do something
like that and he's like well I'm writing
this script right now called The Wedding
Singer and I read it and the girls part
wasn't very developed so they got Carrie
Fisher and Judd Apatow and a bunch of
people to come on and sort of enhance
the parts and you know we ended up
making that film so that's how it came
about not a fortune teller